miércoles 6 de enero de 2021 a las 12 10
donald trump da un discurso a sus
partidarios en washington este ya pasará
a la historia como un ataque a la
democracia estadounidense fueron estas
palabras las que provocaron el incendio
vamos a caminar por la avenida
pensilvania vamos a ir al capitolio y
vamos a tratar de dar a nuestros
republicanos del tipo de impulso y
audacia que necesitan para recuperar
nuestro país
dos meses después de las elecciones
presidenciales donald trump seguía sin
aceptar la derrota y yo bailén aún no
había tomado posesión de su cargo a las
13 y 30 una sesión conjunta del congreso
comienza a certificar la victoria
electoral de yo vaivén pero no esperaban
lo que vendría después
libertad cargué en el capitolio
anarquía los partidarios de trans suben
las escaleras y escalan los muros del
capítulo la policía es incapaz de
detenerlos a las 14 horas la turba
irrumpe en el edificio las oficinas son
saqueadas se rompen puertas y ventanas
la policía del capitolio se ve
desbordada
los amotinados se toman fotos en el
despacho de la presidenta de la cámara
de representantes nancy pelosi junto a
una estatua del presidente fort con una
gorra de donald trump en el pleno del
senado y reina el pánico a las catorce y
veinte se suspende la sesión las puertas
retenidas por las fuerzas de seguridad
están a punto de ser violentadas detrás
de ellas una horda de alborotadores
algunos de ellos armados 25 minutos
después los senadores y el
vicepresidente mike pence son evacuados
otros políticos se refugian en sus
despachos a las 15 horas suenan disparos
y se disparan gases lacrimógenos
mientras se despliega la guarda nacional
más de una hora después yo vaivén toma
la palabra seguido en breve por donald
trump que pide a sus seguidores que se
retiren de freud a la que estas fueron
unas elecciones fraudulentas pero no
podemos hacerle el juego a esta gente
tenemos que tener paz así que vayan a
casa seguro a las seis de la tarde cnc
al toque de queda y la calma regresa el
capitolio queda finalmente asegurado
después cuatro largas horas el congreso
al reanudar su cesión a las 2015 y la
victoria de gobierno se confirmará hasta
las 3 40 de la madrugada del jueves 7 de
enero